[Music]
okay welcome to chess to the 21st
century
now in this lecture I'm gonna lie a
little that's okay because as far as I'm
concerned I'm getting married next week
as far as you're concerned at home I got
married a week ago now you know how long
the videos take to get on YouTube
today's person when I said I was lying
this person was born in the year 2000 so
if you watch the Seinfeld episode you
could argue if it was 21st century or
not okay only if you watch Seinfeld
you don't watch Seinfeld you can't talk
about it okay now Sam Savion is one of
the top players in the country and in
the world and he's the number one 15
year old although I think he's turning
16 as we're speaking and he turned 16
this year so probably in a few seconds
and as soon as he turned 16 he'll be in
the rearview mirror you know looking
looking at Geoffrey Zhang who's even
higher rated but we'll talk about him in
some other lecture this is the last
lecture of 2016 and I mean ever I don't
just mean in chess I mean that's it okay
and we're going to look at two of his
games one was played when he was 12 in
2012
possibly he was 11 nobody knows and I'm
gonna look at a game that he played a
few months ago against Alexi Sharov
which is so crazy I can't do any of
analysis it'll be wrong and I've never
been wrong except when I was wrong
okay the first game doesn't last very
long it's against the French expert
Tatsuo abraham yen unfortunately she's a
French expert not a chess expert no way
this is the French defense not the
language okay and Todd says here right
now she's running the Twitter feed for
the London Chest Classic and that's why
you're smarter than me at home you know
who won the London chefs Classic and I
got nothing over here
no I'm jiske I know wisely so one okay
all right and by the way Topalov came in
last
what a bold prediction alright so this
is 7 vs. taught - have I said it was a
French if you were here in the lecture
earlier and you were not but they were
we saw lots of French's yeah and those
friends
is why play d5 but not this time Knight
c3 okay and here black has two common
moves let's call it an unknown student
Zoey what do you think black can play
here this should be for what of the move
Bishop b4 and what's the name of that
variation it's named after your favorite
player from the 19th century it's Simon
winnow R is it here favorite no he's
nobody's favorite I talked to his mom
and she's like oh come on alright so the
window our variation Bishop b4 is that
what tots have played the answer is yes
very good and when I played the French
defense before your father was born I
also played Bishop b4 doesn't make a lot
of sense because he's older than me but
let's not quibble okay and the other
common move is 9 - f6 grandmasters play
both yes or Sarah one is against Bishop
b4 and even though it's really cold
outside
he's picketing now don't play Bishop b4
ok you can go outside and look it's true
yeah ok so Bishop b4 and as my last
student said in a private lesson who's
yes or Sara Juan
so I teach only the best and brightest
here in st. Louis these are the
Nationals right now ok I wonder if he's
winning
ok Bishop b4 pinning the Knight e5 c5 a3
all very normal to egg stakes the main
line of the winnow waar it's like yuri
showman's black all over again
ok 97 and I've had black in this
position probably more than 30 times but
probably the last time was 1986 ok queen
g4 queen g4 is the most aggressive and
if you learn nothing else today and you
won't sam Savion always plays the most
aggressive move he doesn't kid around I
was telling jokes with him and he said I
don't kid around and he walked away I
was like what I couldn't believe it
right well now you're now you're looking
at the game Fisher Feingold I don't know
that game oh wait yeah I do
okay well now you're talking crazy as
you often do this should be for the
Fisher game with my dad was a three
takes takes takes queen g4 what's funny
is my son started playing this with
Wyatt draw with him yeah but now you're
talking crazy crazy like a fox not like
fox news is that can be edited out not
okay good really well you're not going
to trump that my edit that out
okay well Queen everything is a move but
II five is the main move okay this is
the sharpest the craziest except for
your line okay there's there's sharp and
there's crazy okay now when I was black
here in 1980s I would play Queen c7 and
it's been a long time okay and she
cutting everybody castles now I never
did that when you play the French you're
like I'm not going to Castle I don't
need to castle okay and a lot of people
Castle now in fact Tata has very good
videos on the internet of the French
defense possibly not even on our web
site on a competitor's site okay Bishop
to d3 96 Bishop g5 again Sam always
plays maybe not the most theoretical
move but the most aggressive okay and
sometimes seems King is running around
sometimes he's pushing all of his pawns
sometimes he's losing but he still wins
Queen a5 what's the threat anybody
Bensimon the fork very good Queen takes
c3 check 92 that stops the fork now you
may have noticed this Bishop doesn't
have a lot of squares to go to so c4
could win the bishop but Sam didn't
develop this Bishop not to sacrifice it
okay Sam Sakura
is everything every move so if you force
in a sacrifice he's even happier and if
I can tell us three about myself myself
losing every game about a year ago I had
a very long streak eighteen months in a
row without losing okay and what that
means is I didn't play very much and
when I did my opponents were under 1200
I mean not really but most of that's
true and then I played Sam Savion okay
and I had three and a half out of five
and he had four and a half out of five
and then after the game I still had
three and a half how's that possible
oh yeah I lost and Sam sacrificed
everything they mated me okay then he
started trash-talking I couldn't believe
it
okay so queen a4 and h4r are Sam 7c for
winning the bishop
Sam's very perturbed he doesn't care
King takes King to d2
king daeso is a defensive move
recommended by Ben Simon
now obviously black wants to take this
pawn and then it's very easy to defend
the black King after King d2 Queen takes
pawn is not recommended
most people who sacrifice a bishop then
don't play King d2 that's out there
follow up okay and this is a sacrifice
that's a long-term sacrifice black is up
a piece but Sam seven is not very
concerned about those pieces he's like
yeah you're up a piece good for you
and those pieces can't do anything and
I'm the expert or not doing anything
okay I've been married a week as far as
you know you could ask my wife okay rook
h8 BAM that's good defense putting the
rook on the Open File h5 Knight f5 h6
he's trying to get a queen what's the
only way for black to block up the King
aside g6
yeah now there's no attack so Sam
resigned let's go on to the next game
see that was called a joke see now when
lower weighted players are playing
they're like am i in check and then ten
minutes later they're like nope takes
them about 10 minutes to figure it out
then they're like whose turn is it they
look at the clock then they're like
what's that and then they raise their
hand and ask for the arbiter the arbiter
says that's a clock then they look at
their score sheet to see whose move it
is and they're like wait I didn't write
down to the last eight moves okay and
this is at the low waited players do
them and they're playing when the high
rated player is playing they're trying
to figure out where to put their pieces
okay so for example this is a bughouse
game
now we're getting interesting then white
would play Knight f6 checkmate with
advantage okay and since this is not a
bughouse game we can't do that but we
can try to get our Knight to a good
square there's two good squares for the
White Knight f6 and g5 then we can break
through on the Kings side okay so cm
played Bishop f6 attacking the rook but
he just wants to get his Knight to g5
then he has a pretty good attack okay
rook g8 saving her rook Knight g1 now if
the game ends it all of a sudden like
there was an earthquake or black swag
fell then why would already have three
pieces set up for the next game very
impressive giving himself less work to
do so Knight g1 makes more sense than
Knight f4 then if that scenario happened
there'd be a lot of work to do
now there's two paths to the g5 square
okay and if he really murders them we
could call it a Shining Path no nothing
now nobody okay
so as an old reference all right now you
have to admit 9 g5 would give white the
advantage at home they're like I don't
admit anything ok and well it's
checkmate
so okay so Knight takes d4 we must get a
counter play okay and the idea is if we
take the knight black will play c3 check
the D pawn is hanging Black has a
counter-attack against the King
unfortunately for black if we don't take
the knight
we're just threatening C - so Sam play
trick c1 and said you would taxi - I
defend it with my King you would text
you to defend my rook okay you're not
going to play c3 check and take on d4 I
don't want my piece back all I want is
Knight g5 mate
Knight b5 Knight f3
now even you at home know the threat now
I'm just kidding you know it's Knight g5
mate okay and some of the people here
know the threat let's see Bensimon
what's the threat Knight g5 probably
black should stop that yeah he's like
wait a minute huh yeah what's going on
here so let's see who's the smartest in
the audience how do we stop Knight g5
mate Wow then Knight g5 h7 is annoying
and I know annoying I'm getting married
for the third time exactly or as far as
you know at home did married three times
possibly divorced three times by the
time this video comes out we never know
what is it sentence very good yeah yeah
that's why there's the pros of the
amateurs okay so after Knight g5 White's
looking good
white sacrificed a piece and he's not
very concerned about blacks extra piece
that I would say whites ahead of piece
because these pieces aren't not so good
okay so what did black do anybody stop
mating one heads-up D no no nothin well
she stopped me in one G fine okay at 95
probably wins but I want a beautiful
finish I don't want some easy finish
Queen age five threat
Queen takes f7 if you play rook g6 then
like me the rook is overworked the rook
is stopping Queen f7 in Knight g5 so we
play Knight g5 and if rook takes Queen
f7 mate well not me but it's worse than
mate you're too young to turn away when
you see this it's it's really it's it's
it's not for children yeah there's some
things you don't want to know this okay
and then man check and then double
triple check mate horrible
okay so rook g6 doesn't cut it
she played nine to d6 defending f7 array
okay now very funny move that's not
funny pawn takes Knight hi I tricked you
yeah Knight takes okay now comes the
funny move in this position it looks
like white plays Knight g5 rook g5 Queen
g5 but then black plays I'm calling on
you close 94 winning the Queen yeah so
if I blunder and I was blundering before
you were born
the 94 check wins the Queen right and if
Knight f5 Queen g7 is a nice win because
we double triple discovered mate okay
Sam sevens like man 94 that's a good
defense it's only a good defense because
it's track if it wasn't check it's not a
good defense so he not only played the
move that stopped it from being checked
but like me even before he met me
he might have been in 2012 no he met me
in 2012 he set up for the next game
Bensimon kingi 1 now 94 is not check and
now when black resigned he had less
pieces to set back up very nice
rookie ones legal but kingi one stops 94
check yeah but if you play 94 i matron
your move loses many tempe and doesn't
set up for the next game yeah now in
this position material is about equal
but these pieces aren't aren't so good
over here
not the best okay so Sam actually plays
like the prototypical young child
usually when I'm showing games I'm like
wow this eleven-year-old is a great
positional player it has a lot of
endgame experience somehow and I say
usually kids just sack all their pieces
and mate you but Sam sacks all these
pieces of meet you and then when you get
made you're like dang I got mated okay I
hate when that happens
so Sam's a very tactical player a very
tricky player and he calculates very
accurately even though he's only 11 or
12 years old now that game was tame
compared to the next game the next game
I can't handle take is too hard okay so
is there a thumb I can suck and crawl in
the corner somewhere okay and this is
the game that he played this year
against Alexi shear off now this game
actually makes a lot of sense to show
now because there's a tournament in here
if you never heard of the European rapid
even I haven't heard of it the European
rapid championship and they've played
six rounds and one player has six out of
six cheer-off
so he might be the European rapid
champion as of like two weeks ago for
you okay although probably not I think
he's gonna play good players now yeah
she doesn't do well against good players
but against like me Ben Simon Ben
Conover anybody named Ben then he's
looking good it
nobody knows I think it's a slow game I
think so I'm about my life oke for
because cm plays eforp and they play a
scotch hooray
so now you're happy you're not going to
be happy in a second but you're happy
now
okay Knight f6 Knight takes Knight c3 is
also possible but generally prefer by
lower rated players Queen e2 so they
used to play e5 and then Queen e2 but e5
attacks and Knights we should attack
things too later okay Queenie - not the
most common move Bishop b4 check now
this is sort of a nuance and a lot of
scotches now they're losing a tempo by
allowing white to play c3 and the idea
is your knight can't go to c3 I don't
know okay Bishop goes back in Queen G
for Queen G for every game
King f8 again if we castle as in my
lecture that you didn't see but some of
you did then Bishop h6 could be annoying
could be so King f8 Queenie 4 so in the
lecture I gave before this lecture I was
explaining how the guy who was winning
was moving all of his pieces out and the
other guy wasn't moving any of his
pieces out in this game white just moves
his Queen every move okay on the other
hand black has doubled pawns black has
an isolated pawn and blacks King is on
f8 so what do I know as my dad would say
back in the day both sides stand badly
yeah everything's equal Peter always
says equal yeah I hate the computer
equal I'm like what how does that help
me okay now the Queen on g4 can get
attacked by the bishop on ca and by the
pawn on it so okay Queenie four queens
in the center okay D sec
C 4 and C 4 is explosive yes c4 explain
that to her later you think she knows
hopefully not if she does then you're
not too happy yeah
no nothing perfect good denial we
believe it okay
Knights of b6 Queen takes c6 now if I
was white I would make any of these
moves I develop my pieces in castle and
then I get out plain I lose Sam Savion
doesn't do that he plays the most
aggressive double-edged tricky move and
that's what shear off does so both
players are happy yeah this right this
would be a great match because all their
games would be totally crazy
okay so White's a pawn up blacks Kings
on f8 and white doesn't move in Ava's
pieces so this looks like a game you
would see in a children's tournament
unfortunately for shear of he's not a
child but Sam is so more experienced for
Sam rook b8 okay this should be seven
Queen B five White's made so many Queen
moves nobody can count them all let's
call on a random person Ben Simon
how many Queen was his white made
I don't know it's correct no that's the
correct answer
I'm going to say five Queenie to Queen G
for Queenie for Queen C six Queen B five
okay and why put all of his pieces there
okay but White's a pawn up white can
still castle either way if necessary and
black can never castle so double-edged
ninety seven unleashing on the Queen and
attacking the pawn a thousand times
I like retreats to Edie now it's getting
too complicated Bishop takes d6 Queen g5
if white if white can trade Queens
White's up a pawn and black has two
isolated pawns
okay f6 breaking my rule they don't go
to my lectures very often I could hear
them yelling at home wow you guys are
loud and it allowed in the future I can
hear them that's how loud they are Wow
never play f6 one of my rules Queen age
five now I don't know how many times the
Queen moved I stopped counting Queen e7
check Bishop e2 Bishop g2 establishing
material parity rip g1 Bishop e4 c5 yeah
well who would see c5 I see c5 and I
still don't see it yeah c5 is good
because you make the white squared
Bishop on e2 much stronger Knight c5 rib
g7 the points why did he play rook g7
even if it hung a rook for nothing he
would still do it because he has to
sacrifice okay so it's very obvious that
Queen takes allows Bishop h6 right
Bensimon you agree Queen takes Bishop h6
okay you agree okay if you don't take it
that's probably good for Wyatt because
it works pretty good
okay so King takes Bishop h6 check now
all of you can find the right move
they still didn't find it I don't know
the only legal move King g8 castles if
you play Bishop c4 check I'll play
Bishop d5 check like in the movies in
the movies when one guy checks the other
guy checks back in real chestnuts right
now you know why he played c5 Bishop c4
is coming okay now in my other class is
white wouldn't be able to cast
especially the one o'clock class because
the bishop can go year it's not your er
Bach approved anybody know well you
would home get it they don't get it at
home okay
yuri agra bach was playing perdy and the
position wasn't Purdy and pretty castled
queen site in a similar fashion an avro
bach thought that was illegal and
Purdy's like now he's like okay and
funnily enough I've had two students who
were a player that's already funny and
they Castle queenside in similar fashion
and their opponents who were also a
players stopped the clock and called the
arbiter and said that was illegal
everybody's an a player in both
instances you can't even make this up
the arbiters were a players and I was
thinking if half the eight players in
the country don't know how to Castle
what's the arbor arbiter could make any
ruling who knows and in both cases the
arbiters laughed at my students
opponents so that was good the arbiters
actually knew how to Castle okay if my
comer was the arbiter were you thinking
that because I was and my cover was the
arbiter
anyway castle is legal no matter what
the one o'clock class says okay now
Bishop c4 is pretty serious rook g1
check is annoying Bishop c4 check is
annoying and blacks rook on h8 is of the
best trick ever okay but everybody has
to Sakura okay Bishop g6 nice check 96
is forced Queen h3 threatening to take
out a six reasonable right okay King f7
Knight d5 it's getting annoying now
when you're playing somebody
twenty-seven twenty-eight hundred in
this case twenty seven hundred maybe
even twenty six hundred they're pretty
tricky okay Run DMC tricky they're
tricky tricky they kidding around
okay if you thought rook takes G seven
was amazing
he makes moves you would never consider
like that one very similar to Rick takes
G seven notice that now blacks attacking
got Rick C to check then discovered
everything check winning the Queen maybe
so for example let's look at a variation
it's not going to be right because I'm
looking at it but check check after that
check I could play Bishop to d3 so
actually I'm going to go here actually
I'm going to go here I keep changing my
mind wow I like all these moves for
black I might like rook takes c4 now
this wins but rook takes c4 might also
win and now if you play king a1 Bishop
e5 is annoying if you play Bishop b3 now
I'm starting to like this check and rook
takes Queen yeah
okay so blacks winning so rook takes b2
so King takes be to rip b8 check who's
getting made it over here who's sacking
a rook what's going on around here
Bishop b3 Bishop e5 check Knight back to
c3 so this night spin to the King this
rook is pitting this bishop the bishop
is pinning the knight and the Knights
attacked a couple of times and for some
reason black is up upon seems like
everybody sacks all their pieces there
should be some material disparity but no
okay
so great defense c5 threatening the
explosive move c4 f4 it's not really a
sacrifice because the knight on e6 is
pinned c4 takes
takes who's your money on I would bet on
the guy who the lectures about but if I
didn't know who the lecture was about
it's like a Hollywood movie like okay
that guy's the star then we honor that
guy is so I know who to bet on what's
that actually I made this move in 1990
against Claude Lindenberg in Budapest I
don't know what round it was but he was
meeting me on the queenside I was
meeting him on the Kings side he had a
pawn on b3 and I made the same move not
he made this move how did he block the C
file I mean the B file close a for yeah
I'd played 84 and then I made it him
while he was meeting me but I made it
him first Knight c5 both sides are still
attacking he F Queen c7 44 D a now
materials equal and discovered check
check again now some of you are confused
you're like why didn't he win the Queen
well because you're Queens also hanging
a check it's important that both Queens
are hanging with check then you know
you're playing good chess or that you
should play another game like you know
golf or something because chess is too
hard right
93 King b1 check King c1 check King b2
now blacks mating white or so he thinks
but if he doesn't made them then whites
attack is pretty good so black better
made him check King a3
looks like he's meeting them Queen a1
Queen B - Queen B for King d5
are there more checks
hmm very good winning the game no if he
plays queen c5 there's a queen on e3 so
you distract the King Bishop b4 check
you play Bishop you four and then Queen
takes e4 queen c5 mate and after Bishop
b4 check white resigned yeah an amazing
game because both players sacrificed all
their pieces and both sides had winning
positions according to my engine even at
the same time so both sides sacrificed
to rook both sides were getting mated
and eventually Sam won a week after this
game he was here at the Chess Club I
don't remember why oh I think it was for
the Kasparov chess school I think that's
why no 7 yeah and his dad said did you
see his game with sheer of and I said no
he said you should see it I saw it oh so
he was right yeah and because of players
like Shirov and Savion and Topalov and
MVL and nakamura and many others we have
exciting games like this so if you
didn't like Carlsen car yukkin you're
right okay and it's not because chess is
boring it's because the players make it
boring and if they don't want to make it
boring like these guys and like psycho
dharshan and many other strong players
Wesley so there's a lot of interesting
chess still to be played we don't have
to play nine ten draws in a row if we
don't want to we could have games like
this and and then the players they don't
sleep too well at night because it's
tough then you got to play more chess
after this game and before it's hard
okay so remember if you're playing me
and we have a game like this I offer a
draw okay all right that was chess of
the 21st century
unfortunately for sheer of he's from the
20th century
so not not good yeah that's why I lost
to Sam last time we played it doesn't do
with how good we were it was
I was born in the wrong century alright
see you guys next week and the last
video of 2016
even though you already stopped
recording I'm out
[Music]
you
[Music]